hey everybody and welcome to a rare wild
ride with stevo our guest this week is
special
in many ways
not the least of which is that they
don't do interviews very often how we
got her
crazy who knows but it is paris jackson
and as i tell you this i am on tour in
canada
with
a gorgeous puppy on my lap named roo
which we picked up at
the toronto humane society why because
wendy's afraid of the bus and i could
not do it to her anymore forcing her to
travel around on the bus
so since i don't have wendy on tour i
decided to pick up a foster dog we're
going to find a home for him and i just
want to do that all the time i'd like to
find a home for a dog in every city i go
to
but that's just because i care about the
world
and
also
i care about the environment and that's
why i love liquid death mountain spring
water that's right it comes in
infinitely recyclable aluminum cans
and their mission is to bring death to
plastic that's why it's called liquid
death the cans are super cool they look
like tall boy beer cans
and what else can i say about them they
are so generous that if you go to liquid
death dot com slash stevo
they will give you free shipping on any
order of water
and or merch and their merch is a whole
lot of fun their water is fantastic
and they are saving the world along with
me and rue so
jump on this deal because shipping ain't
cheap and they're giving it to you for
free
by going to liquid death dot com slash
stevo for free shipping on all of your
orders of water and merch now
let's get into it
okay so you rescued her she's sweet how
like how long have you had her i'm
uh
five years and
three days five days or something that
makes sense
she's been around for five years you're
funny
you're so funny
yeah
all right and
let's get you kind of on that mic just
so that we i mean by means pull it over
to you so you can keep playing with
wendy okay
uh oh yeah she really is something else
and uh
and here we go all right
ladies and gentlemen
paris jackson hello hello hello what's
up this that this is quite quite the
honor thank you so much for for coming i
was just telling you that i i felt like
really pretty nervous about about asking
if you would do this why
just because it seemed like a long shot
like uh
i mean i don't know i think like
i mean maybe i'm just that that's just
me i don't know but uh but yeah thank
you for that it was really really cool
um
do you remember
uh we saw each other at uh an acting
studio
i was yeah i was probably like
i want to say
4 13 14 maybe it's been [ __ ] it's been a
full decade yeah it was you were sober
yeah i was sober it was absolutely uh
2012
and uh i i don't even know if i ended up
taking any classes there but um i had
signed with uh that that manager that i
was with for a short time is that were
you getting ready for the uh samuel
jackson no no it wasn't even about the
samuel jackson when he had a cool
mustache for a while yeah
no what it was was that that i signed
with this mansion and they were like
dude you gotta take acting classes this
is a big important thing and i was like
okay cool so i went over to check out
this this acting studio and there was
paris i was like oh well that's cool
i don't know that we really yeah
you were like auditing one of the
classes i think and i was on my way out
because like the teen class had just
ended and so i was on my way out i'm
actually my my best friend that i met in
that uh
class like when i was like 12 13 like
he's still one of my close friends
can you cry on demand
i'd rather not but like i can't it's
possible
you think you can cry in demand how much
you pay i've been trying to cry and i'm
like [ __ ] i'm not watching like legends
of the fall and i see brad pitt cry i'm
like dude how
sometimes menthol helps there have been
times where i couldn't do it menthol
menthol like they'll blow like that's
what i did for i did like a
a music video for a friend of mine the
30 seconds to mars video like a couple
years ago and uh i couldn't cry on
commands so
that one time so they like blue menthol
into my
eyes yeah and let's be clear too that
we're talking about like crying like as
an as a performance yeah and acting but
but what you're saying is that you have
not cried in life i can't
neither i can't cry i you know i i cried
like maybe like a week ago
um for like 10 seconds
and then i was like dude was that cool
you know afterwards and yeah
was that cool this was your homework to
try to cry with your therapist yeah
because i like i it gets stuck here
and i can't like i'll just like and then
i'm like nobody's around i'm like i look
so stupid and i stop
you know you tried breath works
no i feel like that might help i i read
that but i'm like i don't even want to
like
do breath work why not
because i'd rather just like watch
tick-tock no i don't know maybe there's
a way you can find a combination of the
two yeah or menthol or menthol that
works too because like pain doesn't make
me cry
sadness doesn't make me cry being happy
makes me curious beauty yeah you cry i
cry at cirque du soleil shows
do you really i swear i do like because
i'm sitting there just thinking like i'm
so moved by how
totally radical
like this talent is and just like the
the possibilities for what humans are
capable of doing is so moving to me that
i can't stand how rad they are and like
i just start crying but
everybody's watching the show and nobody
knows i'm crying so i just kind of like
you know write it but if any
if i were to speak to anybody they would
be able to tell i was crying but nobody
knows about i cry in secret i'd search
but are you like teary-eyed or are you
like
i'm not audibly crying it's like more
like it's like thank god i'm not in a
conversation because it would be so
obvious i'm crying there's a way to like
just let the tears fall and keep it
i do that a lot
actually yes very like in tune with my
or i try to be in tune with my emotions
that's rad yeah
i remember uh
i think it was like um
i think this is how it happened that
like they're like on some random like
silly thing that i put on instagram i
saw that there was like a comment from
you underneath and i just thought like
wow like paris jackson follows me on
instagram like what a trip read and uh
and so then i followed you back
and uh and then you know ever since then
every once in a while i'll see like wow
she saw my post like that's super cool
and uh and that's why i was able to ask
you if you would do this because i knew
you followed me so i could send you a
direct message and i think it's just it
would fall under the
the counter-intuitive like uh category
to think that like
you know like i think we're an odd
pairing is what i'm getting at sure yeah
yeah it was it was a
pretty solid timing too like when you
messaged me i just so happened to have i
don't check my dms really like ever i've
actually had some of my close friends
get upset because i don't text back i
don't if people call me a pickup
or people want to see me i'll show up
but like i'm i'm horrible with texting
and dming so
it was like kind of by by chance that i
happened to see it
basically why we call it a god shot in
in my world like uh the universe
intended for it to be synchronicity yeah
yeah i just wonder why people are bad at
texting because i respond pretty quickly
i want to i
i don't want to be good at it but i take
it personal when somebody doesn't i'm
like you took three hours
i mean the people in my life that
uh i feel like maybe should stay in my
life or the type of people that are
understanding of it a lot of my a lot of
my friends like have kids and like lives
so
they
they also like oh i want to see you too
i'll see you in november like let's make
plans three months away because it's
like we're both busy we have things to
do i've got like a couple jobs and like
traveling what about someone you're
dating
um what's the best way to get a hold of
you there
they see you make time hypothetically i
don't really call me
i may pick up if it's urgent call twice
that's what i tell people or if they
text you i probably won't respond
i've had i've actually there was one
girl
that
like this is a few years ago we were
fully
we were fully seeing each other i
brought her as a date to like my
uh my cousin's wedding
she brought me as a date to one of her
friend's wedding like it was like going
on for a while and and my way of showing
up is i like to i'll drive out to you
you know if you live in downtown and i'm
living at topanga like i'll drive all
the way like a couple times a week i
don't mind but i won't text you back and
at the end of the day like that was the
deciding factor if it just didn't work
like she just didn't like that about me
and and you know i
a few years go by and i wanted to like
apologize and make it right and then i
ended up doing it again and it's like
it's so a part of who i am that i'd like
to make things right and apologize but
it's it's kind of pointless to apologize
for
for behavior for something that you're
not going to change so i could i could
apologize and be like
were you guys living together no
no we lived on opposite ends of the
fixes just move her in
and then you don't have to worry about
[ __ ] at the time i had like five
roommates yeah and like five animals so
i have that dynamic with our jackass
director jeff tremaine he never responds
to texts and and it hurts my feelings
every time and then i'm like
and then and i'll be like
yeah and uh i just don't get it i'm like
but um but yeah some people just don't
want to be good at texting and you guys
feel about like voice memos
yeah yeah voice a lot of people do that
i'm the best texter in the world he
really is really but that's the problem
he calls it ert his email response time
off the charts like if you had a
business
and you wanted to go into business with
them and you saw like their percentage
of their ert was like a high percentage
like i did i know they get back to me
quick
you know but if they have like a 40 it's
like
yeah i don't want to work with these
people should you do the voice memo
thing no because then if if i listen to
it and i don't respond and i lose it i
don't my ocd will take over and i'm like
[ __ ] did i
imagine that or did i really send it
yeah
yeah that makes sense
right i'm a texter um
so the uh there there was just the
realizing that you followed me on
instagram i got a real kick out of that
and then now that i reached out to you
about doing this
like
i i i just i get the sense that you
don't do a lot of interviews that that
you're like you know like a
fairly private person
you keep uh
text you can't you keep a small story
technology i think that's what it is
yeah i do i keep a small and um and and
i
couldn't help but have this sense i'm
like man i feel like
uh profoundly grateful maybe even a
little bit proud
that i've turned into a guy
that
that you would feel comfortable like
yeah come on i'll come over and have a
conversation on you know
like there's like i feel
i feel like uh i've turned into
i've become a guy that that uh
like
maybe that there's some kind of people
feel there's a reason to trust me like
when they wouldn't even necessarily have
any proof of of that yeah and it's rad
yeah i try not to like judge
people based off of what i see on their
social medias and things like that but i
do for some reason have like a pretty
decent
intuition if i can if i can like see a
picture of someone and i can look at
their eyes it's like a good photo of
their eyes and stuff i can kind of get a
general sense sense for what they'll be
like in person regardless of what the
caption is regardless of what filter
they're using like any of the
whatever product they're selling i can
usually just look at the person's eyes
and kind of get a
and yeah you seem like a smart and like
kind person so oh thank you do you get a
feeling or do you see colors
like oranges yes if i see yours uh i
mean if i tried really hard i could
probably yeah i mean yours is kind of
the trick is to look around the head and
you're in front of something white which
makes it easier i don't know someone
taught me this like years ago and so
what color do you see
kind of like
blue
ish what about the bluish green
i'm like yours is like a darker blue i'm
like wondering like what the hell is
going on and i love how much wendy loves
you
well look at that
do you see any auras in wendy
she's a rainbow unicorn i don't know i
mean
um your eyes could just i don't know if
auras are real or if it's just your eyes
playing playing tricks on you but if you
if you're someone standing in front of
something white you can kind of see
something around their heads but
wow i mean you kind of unfocus your eyes
and look for a color yeah our buddy's
mom likes they're here and then like the
peripheral
like things pop up like a little like
so that's like some uh clairvoyant kind
of
psychic
yeah also i learned that like some eyes
can see more i mean there's obviously
people that are colorblind but then
there's also like more broad spectrum
broader spectrums of color that some
people
can see and some people can't and they
like have certain tests online and stuff
and i did one and apparently i can see
more
than
average i guess like my eyes pick up on
different
that's cool yeah
am i allowed to vape in here is that go
for it yeah yeah it doesn't linger we
were just uh watching ufc fights with
this um this british
superstar of of uh the ufc named patty
the baddie
okay and he was [ __ ]
smoking
spliff after spliff after spliff and i
was thinking to myself god i haven't
subjected myself to this much goddamn
pot smoke in my 14 years of sobriety
this [ __ ] i wish he would stop
with the [ __ ] weed and uh
he's just i was that excited to be
hanging out with them that i let it
slide so you you and your vape is
totally cool well this is this is just
nicotine i don't think you can get
contact high
yeah right
no
yeah i think all the nicotine goes into
your lungs
yeah and we ended up just kind of moving
across to the other side of the the area
and it wasn't so bad um so we just uh
welcomed you to my house and thank you
for for coming here and and you had a
pretty big reaction to my motley crue
shirt
and you showed me that you have a motley
crew tattoo i actually have two i didn't
show you the other one the the second
one i have is uh
wow
oh [ __ ]
wow you really are a hardcore motley
crew fan yeah in like freshman year of
high school i had like
i had that hair the [ __ ] nikki six
hair
layered jet black died i looked like
joan jet like it was
you know i've had like the big
spiky bracelets that got confiscated at
tsa because it's a weapon type thing i
was a very angsty like heavy metal 80s
kid dude that that's so epic um
yeah i i love that so i was going to
tell you that um
when i when i was 13 years old no i'll
tell this quickly
um
super motley crew fan it was 1987
and i lived in toronto
and they had their girls girls girls
tour so the day before the concert
i saw on the news they were like
they were in some kind of trouble they
set a hotel room on fire some weird [ __ ]
and it was on the news that they were
like
these jerks are in our city doing this
stuff and and i'm like just freaking out
because i'm like the con the concert's
the next day
so i arrive at the conclusion that
they're in a hotel
and like i'm gonna [ __ ] track him
down so um i i went right into my room
to uh get the name of their manager from
my album sleeves on the tape cassettes
okay and it was doc mcgee and then i
went running to the phone book the
yellow pages and i called every single
hotel in the yellow pages starting at
the top
and asking for a room please put me
through to doc mcgee's room and called
for [ __ ] hours and hours and uh then
i ultimately was patched through to a
hotel room and this guy answered the
phone i was i said is that doc mcgee and
he says no this is doc's brother scott
and and i'm like freaking out i'm like
as in motley crue it's the crew there
and he's like how'd you get this number
and i told him i just called every hotel
in the yellow pages and he was like man
that's [ __ ] awesome how would you
like backstage passes for the show
tomorrow night and so
i then they gave me fifth row tickets
and so um yeah i was 13 years old and my
dad took me and and um we sat in the
seats i got and and dad took photos of
me with tommy lee and nikki sixx that is
awesome what was your dad like i i can't
imagine your dad like at the concert
fifth row dad was just stoked like the
thing was that um
this was before they had like call
waiting you know so if uh if you're on
the phone then the other person's just
gonna get a busy signal there's no beep
to click over and
so i was tying up the phone it was a
saturday
dad was like watching football in the
living room mom was annoyed that i was
tying up the phone mom says hey stop
tying up the phone and i'm like mom i'm
calling motley crue
my dad
was kind of observing what was going on
he uh had never seen me quite so on fire
for something like you know he could
tell i was turned on i was like uh just
driven in this thing and that's all i
ever wanted for me i was just one bad
report card after another constantly in
trouble a [ __ ] nightmare like wake up
like apply yourself you [ __ ] [ __ ]
and here i was and so dad told mom like
you know honey back off like he's
calling molly crew you know and dad like
allowed it so they answered the answer
to your question like what was dad like
during the concert he didn't [ __ ]
care he was stoked that his kid was on
fire for something you know yeah that's
pretty cool and i described that whole
experience as having kind of turned me
into a monster because there was nothing
for me to say to nikki sixx or tommy lee
but the fact that i was standing next to
my heroes because of just my pure will
to do so like it was so empowering that
like it really gave me the sense that
that i could
there's no limit to what i can
accomplish if i really [ __ ] go for it
you know and i feel strongly about that
in
in life in general it was so rad
i was kind of around the same age when i
first saw them play are you seeing them
in like a week i think they're playing
like a week two weeks were there at the
staples center i would it was on my
calendar for the longest time but uh i'm
on tour myself so i i head out for a
tour tomorrow good for you i'm sure
they'll be back around yeah i mean
whatever dude i'm not tripping it's uh
it's all good and um
i don't need to be in another [ __ ]
big marijuana cloud like i was with
patty the betty yeah
what kind of grades did you get in
school were you did you get in trouble a
lot did you not get in trouble um
it may not come as a shock to learn that
when i was a kid i found myself in a lot
of hairy situations but these days not
so much because it's so easy for me to
have a nice smooth fresh clean shave
thanks to the good people at harry's
harry's brings us the best men's shaving
products
out there i mean the five blade razor
that stays sharp for ages and it's all
so affordable man i remember back in the
day when i was just throwing money away
on gimmicky razors that
vibrated like
heated up like all this nonsense that
was just totally unnecessary and as soon
as i switched to harry's i felt like
just a cooler guy man like i don't need
all the gimmicks and the bells and
whistles i got classy shaving products
that work extremely well i've never
wanted to turn back and by the way i've
been using harry's for a long time since
before i got into business with them on
this podcast that's why they're one of
my favorite sponsors of this podcast and
bless them for having such a wonderful
deal for you guys if you go to harry's
dot com slash devo you're gonna get
yourself a starter kit which comes with
the five blade razor the travel case to
protect the razor the weighted ergonomic
handle the foaming shave gel
and
a body wash and this
all comes in at a value of 16
but the listeners of the wild wild ride
podcast will get it for just three bucks
how about that that's worth becoming a
harry's customer just try it because i
did and i loved it and i've never turned
back and neither will you plus it's
going to save you a whole bunch of money
so one more time go to harrys.com
to get this killer starter kit and
become a harry's loyalist like me
yeah harry's dot com slash stevo now
let's hear about paris when she was a
kid
remember you seem pretty mellow have you
always been like this
yeah just shatter um i was always pretty
like uh kind of like stuck to myself uh
oh i was home schooled for the first
like six grades and i did fine yeah that
way i just i learned better when it's
one-on-one or like with my brother and
then i went to like a private school in
l.a for a few years i struggled there
in part because i just didn't have
social skills and then the other part of
it was fully like my undoing like i
didn't like fitting in and i i enjoyed
the things that
made me look a little scarier like the
motley crue stuff and the combat boots
with my uniform like i loved that and i
liked getting uniform violations i liked
getting detention
and so you know i had some struggles
there but a lot of it was like i will
take full accountability for it
some of it was like out of my hands and
then um
[Music]
i did all right in like the right
right-sided stuff of your brain like the
the artsier stuff and like language and
things like that other than spanish i
was horrible spanish um
but like the maths didn't do i did in
science i didn't do well in those i
would like just barely pass every year
and then i did like school in utah for a
couple years and then i finished early
because i was just i was done so by the
time i came back to l.a i was like i
want to finish a year early i want to be
done so you didn't play any sports in
high school or um
nothing that i was like really like good
at yeah like i was like kind of kind of
decent at a few of them
uh like volleyball was kind of just like
easy because i'm tall that's all you
really
for like for like school sports like
is the height when it comes to
especially in high school if you're tall
like you're taller than the most yeah
and uh on my dad's side of the family i
think it's like maybe my dad's cousin
um this my dad's cousin jane glover is
this like super famous orchestra
conductor lady and at one point we were
over in england and we went to see one
of her shows which was attended by the
the royal duchess of kent which is like
this royal family lady and i was just a
little kid
and um the the we met the the duchess of
kent and she asked my sister like you
know what do you are you a musician as
well and you know and then
and then uh the duchess of kent asked me
do you play anything and i said yeah i
played baseball
that's funny it was and i didn't think i
was being funny but uh but yeah i think
that what made me think of that is that
you're
probably the other way around where
scott's asking you did you do any sports
and you were like well no i played
instruments yeah like i played music
yeah yeah i've always been into the into
the music thing mainly like it was just
a hobby for a long time and then in the
last few years i was just like this is
way more than the hobby this is like a
massive part of who i am as a person and
it's it's my favorite thing in the world
so um playing music yeah
writing playing learning um anything
involved like i'll spend i didn't read
for a long time i used to be an avid
reader as a kid i just recently in the
last few weeks like started picking up
books again ooh i got a book coming out
next month really yeah myself i'll read
it yeah actually i will what book made
you want to get back in the reading
ishmael yes
by daniel quinn i name it as my second
most important book to read that's the
first one uh conversations with god book
one by neil donald walsh i haven't read
that okay wait uh where's my yeah will
you message me and like that that is
okay so this is from ishmael this tattoo
i have don't you have an ishmael tattoo
yeah i don't have an ishmael tattoo no
this is from so each every time you hit
a new chapter there's a little bamboo
thing okay every chap that's what that's
from that's so cool that you guys have
read that's my favorite book yeah i mean
it's
it's it's
an important book because like to read
it is so like kind of depressing like
you you walk like i remember like
reading it and like walking through an
airport and just thinking like none of
this is supposed to be this way like
this is [ __ ] awful like we're like
where the human race is such uh
like
like i mean it's not like virus like
back like a virus but real almost like
just a cancer you know like a cancer on
the world like it's so uh and it's such
a wonderful way that that book you know
just using this relationship between a
gorilla and this this kid like
you know must that like have an earnest
desire to save the world like it's the
most preposterous uh fictional novel
with the the most deep
and
real
like like like wisdom about about the
the dangers of uh humanity
i don't mention the gorilla when i tell
people about it that haven't read it
right i listened to the audiobook and
the gorilla's voice was phenomenal
really i haven't read it i don't i
really do i don't listen audiobooks it
was like a an interesting accent i think
it was like maybe even english like if i
can recall
but what was what was the book that got
you in the reading
book that got me into reading i mean i
remember reading as a kid like uh i
hated reading as a kid and then i loved
it there's a book that i loved as a
kid called my side of the mountain and
there's this kid who ran away from home
lived in the mountains like had this
hollowed out tree yeah i remember i read
that book in fifth grade and that book
made me just so stoked to run away from
home
and what was extra rad was that this kid
ran away from home lived in a tree like
lived off the land and then at the end
like his family fell on like terrible
hard times and they all like
like moved into trees with the kid who
ran away from home so he was like bailed
his family out and he was just like the
man at the end
that's cool
what about your favorite book as a kid
as a kid
i don't know um i just i read so much
because that was like our form of
currency growing up like my my brothers
and i like my dad wanted us to like
trading books well not necessarily so we
um we weren't just like handed things
like we we lived life in like a silver
spoon kind of way like we literally had
everything i never had to worry about
like my next meal or roof over my head
whatever it was like i got to see the
world but things weren't just like the
good stuff wasn't just like thrown at us
we had to like work for it so
our dad had us use like books as
currency so it's like oh if we're going
to fa shorts and you want five toys well
you have to read five books and i will
quiz you on it and so i like read all
seven chronicles of narnia in a week
like i woke up at six a.m read the first
book finished it by bedtime and then
next day did the same thing and in seven
days i finished the whole [ __ ] uh and
that was like
i got seven toys you know what i mean
like that was
that was uh that was our currency we
like had to earn it and books are like
knowledge is power is what he used to
say and books my dad said that
knowledge is power
i remember like
i was at some uh
some
some
food drive like to
give food away and
some some
person there's just like oh you know
you're you need to go you need to be
saved by jesus and i was like dad i'm
just frustrated this guy with his like
my dad's like well the next time someone
does that like uh you know ask them you
know this question about like the
original greek scriptures and how the
the
the the bible was translated from greek
and the the love what was lost
from greek
yeah and uh my dad just he was like you
know asking this question bet you they
won't have the answer and knowledge is
power and i was like yeah rad ask them
how old the earth is
and they'll say yeah eight thousand
years old i articulated that really
poorly but but there was another
person
who uh
left some some comment oh god man you
know like you need to be saved by jesus
and and i and i
i wrote back i replied to this person
said yeah you know you're totally right
but i'm just gonna like wait and and
for later you know and and jesus can
save me later and i know that that like
when i accept him later that that will
wash away all the bad stuff i do between
now and then so it's all cool and jesus
rules
yeah
which was just a [ __ ] thing for me
to do it was kind of an [ __ ] comment
to leave but was this like a youtube
comment yeah and i can't don't current i
know i can't i can't sometimes i can't
help it do you have a youtube channel no
but every now and then i'll see i i go
on twitter like maybe once a month
because like i don't really do the dms
and things like that but like once a
month maybe once every other month i'll
just like go on there and see what's up
and every now and then things are just
like too good to not respond to
yeah but you're probably responding to a
bot
sometimes sometimes it's a little too
specific to be a bot so one of them my
favorite one that i actually had
retweeted and pinned on my profile was
someone was like do you have it yeah i
retweeted it and pinned it was just a
message where someone was like do you
have any idea how much of a
disappointment you are to your family
and i was just like this is just i like
retweeted it and pinned it um
did you retweet with comment or
i retweeted it with did you guys see
those like videos where people are
it's like this narration with the arctic
monkeys song and it's like
have you ever uh
been beaten by your girlfriend with a
wet spaghetti noodle because she has a
twin sister and you got confused and
[ __ ] her dad well that's how it feels
to drive a ford f-150 it's like this
like narration and i just retweeted that
with that narration as like over wow
i've always wanted to do it like a show
where you get like you find the meanest
comment on one of your things right with
like what they do on kimmel like mean
tweets yeah but but
there's a team of hackers it's a tv show
there's a team of hackers that finds the
ip address go to the house and then and
then the guy comes home and then chris
hansen's in the kitchen like please have
a seat and then you read the tweet like
you said this thing to me and
why would you say that like it really
hurt or whatever just exposed who the
person is yeah i don't know that feels
even more invasive
invasive than them hoping that you die
of cancer and you're a piece of [ __ ]
right but at least you've gotten some
gnarly stuff like that i mean it's an
art but it's like but why would somebody
go that deep and it's like i want to see
who said that like what
what's going on bud
if it's if it's super creative then i
almost respect them
you know like there's some really
creative ones if it's funny of course
there are some ones that like flow very
nicely like if you read it out loud the
way like calling someone a sick [ __ ]
like the way that easy phonically sounds
like somebody's
if somebody says like you know
something's so [ __ ] dark it's like
bro
right where does that come from yeah
right how you could just respond and
tell them that they need jesus yeah
that's true too the best is if you just
respond tldr
too
and then they'll respond and you just
keep saying tldr and they lose their
[ __ ] oh my god that's so good
ah i think it made me think forget what
what i was thinking
um
yeah i know what it was there's a couple
times where i was like man i felt like
resentful towards somebody and like
i uh you know felt the urge to um like
speak out negatively like you know about
like whatever i was feeling resentful
about
and then what has stopped me from
from doing that
is thinking to myself
would tony hawk ever do that like no god
no tony hawk would never like
publicly speak out like negatively about
somebody so as to tarnish their
reputation so you're more like wwth yeah
wwth what would tony hawk do and then
as it relates to
dealing with negative comments
it's all about what would dana white do
dana white is just so on [ __ ] phased
by any negative [ __ ] comment he's
[ __ ] he's like he's [ __ ] stupid
[ __ ] [ __ ] up you know like
and uh i want to be more like dana white
and i want to be more like tony hawk
yeah
no negativity and just not
affected by negativity either
yeah sometimes it's easy sometimes it's
right i mean sometimes you get high off
of it because you're like blood
you get a little rush right
but um let's talk more about your music
that like uh
do you have a
full album out
uh i have yeah my my debut album came
out um
[Music]
in end of 2020. so i did all of that
during like covid like flew to georgia
made a whole record in like two and a
half weeks and then within like a couple
months it was out wow and what's your
record label i understand it was
republic yeah so well i made the album
before i signed with them and then um i
got a meeting with uh monty uh one of
the record executives and uh the a r
the yeah the whole the whole uh
department and things like that i met
with him and i played him the whole
album and he wanted to hear it like in
track order and i was like you sure you
want to sit with me for 45 minutes and
like listen to all of this he's like
yeah play for me so i stuck the burn cd
and i played it for him and he's like
all right cool so when do we start like
when do we sign and that's awesome
awesome and then um
and since then i put out like a couple
singles and uh like a short folky ep and
i've been working on some other stuff
with um
a few friends cool that i'm excited to
put out i saw you uh perform music on
jimmy fallon's show on your instagram
that was awesome it was a stellar
performance to look at it you might
think that paris really takes care of
herself
and to look at me you would think i am
definitely taking care of myself can you
believe i'm 48 years old and
killing it on a skateboard roaming
around all over the world in just
tip top shape and a big part of the
reason for that is
athletic greens that's right man it's
because my
diet
has no gaps because they're all filled
in with ag-1 from athletic greens and
what is that well it's the most
convenient comprehensive daily nutrition
comes in a packet or a big thing with a
scoop and it is delicious it's loaded
with 75 different vitamins minerals
whole food sourced
superfoods
probiotics adaptogens it helps with your
brain health it makes you think better
it helps with your gut health it fills
in the gaps of your diet so that you've
got all the nutrition you need plus it
tastes delicious and it just makes you
healthier and happier plus if you go to
athleticgreens.com
[Music]
well if it's your first time then you're
gonna get
five free
travel packs with the comprehensive
convenient daily nutrition plus an
entire year's supply of immune boosting
vitamin d
that is a big generous offer from the
good people at
athletic greens and it is available to
you if you go to athleticgreens.com
telling you it's time to
jump on top of your health and that
starts with your diet so one more time
athleticgreens.com
stevo
and get that deal now
let's talk about fallon
yeah that was so fun i'm usually like
i'm my hardest harshest critic so
sometimes i'll see videos of like
performance that i just did and i'm like
not nice to myself i'm like i could have
been better there there there the
fallon one was the was one of the only
ones where i'm just like no i'm
satisfied with that like i'm actually
you're [ __ ] feeling it and i felt
right i feel good yeah i felt good
there's a lot of i've learned too that
like i
especially with the way i'm singing now
i kind of have stopped with the sounding
like how i think i'm supposed to sound
because i did that for a long time just
using a prettier softer voice and now
i'm just sounding like me
and that
in a bright eyes conor obvious kind of
way is not a tone that a lot of people
love
it's like uh and a bright eyes uh oh you
know the band bright eyes like
they're like uh they're like early
2000's but like the guy's voice he's one
of my favorite singers he's one of my
favorite
artists um some people aren't like a
huge fan of like the tone that he uses
and how he sings and same thing with the
band future islands like i love
kind of uh
just like it's different it's not like a
conventionally good voice they're not
doing anything wrong they're not like
hitting a wrong note but the way they
sound is just not what people
you're not going to hear it on like a
mainstream radio station because it's
just not as digestible that's what i'm
around for digest it's not digestible
like if i were to sing
sure yeah sure
yeah so i just like i don't know it's
it's more i'm using a tone that feels
more authentic to myself and that's not
something that people love
all the time uh so the fallon thing
definitely was i got some blow back with
with how i'm singing now which is
which is fine just negative comments do
you get nervous before you perform oh
yeah because
i'm curious to know your thoughts
steve makes me do stand up for him
sometime and like i gotta go somewhere
else 20 minutes before the show don't
talk to me don't look at me i'm so
nervous i'm pacing and steve's just like
you know
on a facetime call right before he gets
up he's running late and he's just like
he doesn't
not bother at all and i even looked at
we did we checked his uh his heart rate
before her show
mine's like 165 170 like eject
he's just like that's it's 58.
like do you
how have you been doing it
six months i hate it i don't know how
long have you been doing it i've been
doing it for a long time but how long
have you been doing it you've been doing
it for a while so
if i'm about to play a show that's like
a small hotel cafe kind of thing and
it's just me and my acoustic guitar no
nerves whatsoever because i that i've
been doing for a long time i've been
playing in like tiny local venues and
like doing whatever like for for a while
now yeah and so i've gotten very
comfortable with that like phoebe buffet
pardon phoebe buffet i don't know that's
from friends the the girl he's playing
oh yeah exactly the cat she sings that
song i don't know too much about friends
but i know that there's like a cat song
um yeah so that i've been doing for
a long time for me a long time um
but the having a band and like doing
like the louder stuff is is pretty brand
new
so playing a festival like boston
calling they were like by the end of my
set there was like i think over a
thousand people in the
um
like my section of the audience which
was for me a lot of people
and i was so nervous beforehand and like
i get nauseous i have to take like a
pepto or tommy for sure
are you like don't talk to me just leave
me alone i'll [ __ ] my pen no i i like to
huddle with my band
my before show pro if i'm really nervous
i'll like i'll i'll huddle with them and
and i love my band they're all like
they've been doing this for a while
they're like hired guns they play in a
lot of bands together and um they're
they're older than me too so they they
can like call my nerves they're like you
know what you're doing like we got you
yeah i definitely can
be nervous like especially like you know
taping a special like that'll make me
super nervous like even like taping like
uh
you know just
taping the show to show to important
people or if there's important people at
the show like anything that kind of
raises the stakes of the show what will
give me nerves and uh i remember too i
had this crazy experience like um
it's kind of kind of inappropriate for
me to share but uh but i was i was um
the speaker at a big 12-step meeting
and uh and i remember being really
nervous getting up to speak in front of
like whatever it was like a 100 150
people
super nervous and i remember going
directly from there
to go sit down with mark maron on the
marc maron podcast
and
all of a sudden now i'm speaking to
like [ __ ] millions of people
and i was so totally like
just sitting there with mark maron
talking on the microphone like no nerves
at all and it was millions of people
listening compared to where i had just
been so nervous in front of like 100
people so
well it's funny the way you show your
nerves because i've seen you
two instances i can recall being nervous
the first time
was
when you filmed your uh guilty as
charged and when you walked out in the
audience and and
it was i think it was just so
overwhelming that like you took a beat
for uh
extra longer than you should have you
know and it was kind of like a lot to
take in and then and then
when when when we showed the uh
the skyjacking bit at in miami with your
dad in the audience and you came over
and you were just like giggling you know
you're just like oh dude like i just
thought that was interesting of like a
display of
the same emotion but two different ways
yeah i've got a really ridiculous show
that i tour with
called the bucket list show and uh
it it's a multimedia show where i talk
about like just the craziest ideas that
i ever had and i never thought i would
actually do that but then i did
and so i show the footage of these
things happening and one of the things
is called skyjacking where i literally
go skydiving for the first time ever
completely naked with another man
strapped to my back
and
masturbates completion and
simultaneously fall out of the airplane
as i'm ejaculating all over the place so
he's got his dad in the audience his
wife my dad his sister their friends
their family you know and we knew it was
coming we're just like oh [ __ ] that that
was enough to make me nervous that's
awesome though
what was this when did i do it it's been
a few years since we actually taped that
bit yeah yeah that was one of the first
things we taped for the bucket list show
um it's all pretty high level stuff
like super super the top stuff that i
would never have been able to do for
jackass and uh calling around the
different companies to let us do that
was was interesting it was a challenging
bit yeah it was it was a wildly
challenging bit um so when you're uh you
know i was thinking about like you know
you um
were describing being you're being
homeschooled and and you're sort of like
you know i picture just sort of in
general you're not like a super
extroverted person you know you're kind
of kind of quiet like and then i wonder
how much that's at odds with just
getting out on stage and just rocking
and like letting it loose
um i can be very extroverted i can be
very but i have a meter like i i can um
at times be like the life of a party i
know how to
uh i know how to network i know how to
strategize i am a big part of like being
in the fashion industry as well as the
music industry is making appearances and
meeting people and talking to people
making friends um and so
i'm able to turn that on
um
but i'm definitely for the most part
like very very introverted i like i can
be very extroverted with like a small
group of people as well that's a lot
easier and that's more organic
um
the
it depends on the audience though if i'm
performing like how big i'm gonna go it
depends on the audience like for the
boston show that i just did
that was
wild because it was the biggest stage
i've ever played like the size of it
like i was able to run top speed back
and forth and that i'd never done before
but it just like it happened and like
the audience was feeling it and i was
feeling it and i had like
i'd never performed like that um so far
that was like the first time like really
giving it that much energy
and
i saw like
a good portion of the audience all like
moving their heads like this in in sync
with each other and i'm like okay most
of these people have never heard my
music before and i'm getting them to
have this kind of reaction that feels
great that hypes me up i'm going to keep
going and i'm going to make it bigger
and i'm going to yell louder and i'm
going to like really project
but then there have definitely been
times where people are just like not
feeling the sad or like uh so you're
kind of feeding off the crowd and what
their energy is and so
it either uh it goes kind of one
direction or the other
yeah i'm one of the
the last tour that i went on one of the
first
shows that we did i was opening up for
this um
kind of like a bluesy
john mayery kind of dude i don't want to
compare him to another artist but that's
what it makes me think of um and we were
in vegas we're like the small venue in
vegas and it was like on the outskirts
of vegas too so it wasn't where like the
party is and it was like a relatively
empty venue because they're not here for
me they're here for the guy that they
bought the tickets for like i'm just the
opener um so that was just like kind of
like a dead show and i was just i was
like looking over at my guys i'm like
all right let's power through like let's
just let's get through this
so it kind of it depends
so
talk to us about the fashion industry i
don't know i feel like i've seen you
um
kind of in in that
how many countries have you been to
because of fashion
because of fashion um like yeah how many
countries have you been to their fashion
week
oh um
only
for sure france oh yeah that's the one
that i go to that that's my go-to is
paris fashion week i try and go uh twice
a year
i still have yet to go to milan fashion
week that's a bucket list for sure um
and then i've done london a couple times
and new york if you and when i first
started like six years ago i did new
york fashion week a lot because i was
with calvin klein so when um
when you started six years ago in what
capacity did you start
um modeling yeah i first started with
the modeling like runway
no actually my debut
runway like proper fashion week runway
was walking for gautier and uh paris
fashion week right before kovet hit and
it was uh jean-paul gutie's final show
as a designer before like doing like
this whole retiring thing like 50 years
in the business and it was like
it was huge i remember like going to the
casting and like doing it and being so
nervous because i had
i've done like auditions and castings
for acting in fashion and been told no
before um because i'm well aware of like
my platform and how my name can get me
into a room but whether i get the job
that's dependent upon like am i capable
of it and you know versace told me no
before because my walk just wasn't
it like i just didn't have the walk yet
and that crushed me but then when i went
to the casting and i got the goatee gig
like that was like
so it felt really good and i knew that a
massive part of that i had earned and um
i was able to do it and i didn't trip i
was wearing like six inch wedge heels
and that happened a lot people tripping
yeah especially in like the shoes that i
was in like there were their stairs
sometimes on the runway so if you uh
it's a lot easier to fall if they're
stairs and you're wearing like six inch
like
stilettos or wedges yeah i feel like if
you were if you do a youtube search for
like
models eating [ __ ] on the runway there's
probably like mass compilations yeah so
many people i feel like i feel like
everyone falls at least once
i feel like that's pretty it's gotta be
a rather passage you fell
i have not yet yet though i mean it's
you know are you even a model if you
haven't fell
no
that's epic and so when when uh when
you're doing this like
high-level fashion stuff is it like it's
got to be obnoxiously lucrative huh
what do you mean
like uh to to walk the runway for go ta
like is there like a bunch of money that
comes with that
um i think it depends on
the person and it depends on i mean i
got like a standard a standard rate
right they usually depends on the brand
okay depends on the brand some i'm sure
you you you walk for free
some of them it's like they'll pay you a
lot
no you never get to keep the clothes
yeah yeah i feel like it's all
especially that goatee one a lot of it
was archival which is like some of it's
like priceless
yeah like like kim kardashian wearing
the marilyn monroe dress yeah that's
like uh that's a very like priceless
kind of kind of yes i have one actually
one of my favorite things that i own is
uh one of lee alexander mcqueen's
designs uh from his fall winter
collection in 2007
and um i like wore it in the music video
and i ended up buying it it ended up
like fitting me perfectly which usually
never happens because i'm not i'm not
sample size um so the fact that it like
fit me was like really exciting and
sample size is like a fit model
it's like this yeah sample size like the
standard that they usually
um design for and then um you can tailor
it once the
once it's been
is that the same size as the mannequin
yeah not the beauty yeah that would be
no that would be that would be sample
size yeah so there have been times where
i have fit into sample size before and
also every brand is different like ysl
sample size is a lot smaller than like
say
uh gautier why
the for for the people who maybe who
don't know is eve saint laurent wow yeah
you're saying goatee and i'm thinking
about the song somebody i used to know
that's like like oh cool sounds a little
different it sounds the same though
sounds the same
um
so so you get the the music is popping
off the fashion is popping off
have you uh where's the acting at
acting's cool uh i've done i've done a
few like cool things that i'm i'm proud
of
um
nothing as a super i mean i did
something in april it's not out yet um
but
nothing on the horizon right now so
right you know we'll see and um like in
the ditch of course you have the
instagram but uh but this is the
instagram yeah
but you don't um
you don't have your own youtube channel
or anything i i do i'm not the one that
runs it though same with like facebook
facebook i don't i haven't used the
facebook since i was like 17. i used to
have like my own personal account now
there's like a main account that's run
by a team so so for for the youtube um
the youtube that gets run by somebody
else what kind of stuff goes on your
youtube channel like uh the
music videos and stuff lyric videos for
like my music and things like that it's
mainly music focused okay my chemical
performance my family performance and um
have you made music videos for your
songs that are just like legit
yeah there's there's a few
uh the first really big one
was to promote the my debut album and
that one was was wild because we had
like eli roth consulting and the the
chick that did the uh ballroom scene and
beauty and the beast she was our like
main choreographer those people like
that team was our meeting and the beast
with the the chick from harry potter
yeah yeah we had like a remarkable team
and we did it all in like one night it
was like one of the bigger budget ones
and uh it was like a short film and i
was so proud of that one um my heart
gets ripped out at the end and you can
like see it eating and i'm like bleeding
on the floor it's very dramatic and i
learned how to waltz for that video like
it was a whole i took lessons
that one was super fun and then one of
the more like mellow ones uh was a duet
that i did with like my hero um
and it was more like we were playing
with light and photography and i suppose
i was like creative director and i
specifically asked for like someone that
is more
of an expert with photography as opposed
to directing because i wanted to like
play with light and silhouettes and like
chopping up our faces and putting them
together kind of thing not in like a
gory way but in a editing way the uh i'm
i still can't get past your heart being
ripped out and it's beating i'll send it
to you after i leave here it's and it
starts when it's like beat and stand so
your heart is ripped out but presumably
by a hand and it's a hand holding a
heart that's beating it's like my lover
in the video
wow
and and uh do you find that with your
music videos on youtube that the um the
the viewership on it is just like
insanely
high like i mean in general i think
music videos on youtube get like a ton
of views i think it depends on the
artist like i've gotten like
i don't know i think i think that video
the heart one maybe has two or three
million okay which is significantly
lower compared to like a lot of artists
getting like
999.9 million yeah
i'm like i'm not uh by any means
uh
like a super like well-known musician
like my music isn't like super super
well known i like i have a couple like
friends that are in local bands and
stuff and i'm in the same like monthly
monthly listener category as like a lot
of my like l.a fan friends you noticed
too as well that with the music videos
on youtube that it's not even youtube
it's like vevo yeah
like i don't really know like the
difference
yeah i don't know maybe they bought vevo
out and they just
get all the money for it if you have if
you can drive traffic of everybody
listening to one song of yours
that's out right now which song would
that be
adagio
but people it's one of the it's more
it's less of a song and more of a
demonstration it's like over six minutes
long yeah okay and that's it that's got
its own youtube link yeah there's no
there's like a like a dark lyric video
attached to it i did it with my favorite
band in the world so that was very
exciting for me well what's your
favorite brand in the world manchester
orchestra they're like my alt
manchester orchestra oh manchester
united
you think of manchester united i was
thinking i was thinking the mahabhishni
orchestra which is john mclaughlin this
jazz musician i like
you like jazz yeah i mean i've liked it
in the past
with any pat matheny
george benson earl
guy clue picks me up one time and he's
listening to this and i'm like
what are you listening to he's like
jim benson
like he's like yeah he used to perform
with earl clue like
excuse me
yeah exactly the only reason i know
those names is because steve listens to
that yeah i mean i don't know
i'm a weird guy what do you want no i
just thought it was funny because you
were like yeah it's a no-brainer so um
so for uh you know like we put this
podcast out on like
like every audio platform that podcasts
exist and then we have youtube as well
and it's like for the youtube version we
can put in like the description youtube
links to these songs so okay sweet
anybody consuming this on youtube can
just go to the video description and
find the links we got to put the beating
heart in there
sure yeah that the heart ripped out and
then the adagio one
that one's my so far my favorite uh song
of mine that's like out um
partially because like literally my
favorite band i did it with them but
also because it's just uh if i like if i
don't know if you guys are radiohead
fans but they're like another favorite
of mine isn't radiohead the band that
like reformed with like practically the
same lineup as a different name the
smile that's the new yeah it's johnny
and tom from
uh from radiohead they're like doing
like a and weren't they something before
they were radiohead
they
stereo face
they have um i mean i know tom york does
like a lot of different side projects
like he also has one called like atoms
for peace which is which is solid and he
does stuff under
under tom york he did the entire like um
soundtrack versus spirit like the remake
of suspiria which is
fit like a fantastic uh soundtrack and
um another one you can throw in there
it's not a youtube link it's a netflix
thing but it's a 15-minute short film
that tom york did with paul thomas
anderson to support anima which was a
good album of his
one of the greatest pieces of work i've
ever seen that sounds like it doesn't
have anything to do with you though i'm
just a fan of it i'm just a fan so yeah
we're not putting that in there i'm just
trying to get together
i just want thomas to love me
what does adagio mean adagio in slow
tempo it's um so i'm like here like
low-key [ __ ] on jazz i listened to
classical i mean i grew up like she was
like
jazz in college um no adagio for strings
by samuel barber is one of my favorite
songs and it's um
it was kind of the title of it was like
kind of homage to samuel barber who's
like a fantastic uh composer but i i
grew up listening to some classical and
sometimes i still listen to it yeah
right right on it's just so uh
but there's a motorcycle that you wrote
here this is a scooter it's not a
basketball yeah it's a little piglet i
will one day get a hog but right now
it's just a little piglet man my girl um
like owned a motorcycle
and i was like you gotta get rid of that
[ __ ] thing like
it's so dangerous yeah uh how far do you
drive that thing
i've taken it up to topanga from
like around this area before yeah
because i i have a motorcycle and it's
like it's rough to ride that thing if
it's not like a i bought a royal infield
no [ __ ] yeah dude that's the one that i
want to get right i want to get a royal
enfield i i i rode around india which by
the way got picked up on indie flicks
yeah
yeah when did that happen i signed the
contract like last week and so they're
gonna air it on indie flicks it's a
pay-per-view i rode a motorcycle around
india for a month
and then i've like filmed myself going
to different like ashrams and meditation
places and then i loved it so because i
wrote a royal enfield over there that i
bought one when i got home and i just
keep it at the warehouse and i ride it
around but if it's it's like a 499 cc
and it's
if you're writing topanga like it's a
[ __ ] to write on the freeway you know
if it's not like
a powerful one up and down the hills and
like there's so much that can go wrong
but and so i try to like just take it
for a driver i remember i was riding
from malibu to here
and uh and i was you know my helmet was
all [ __ ] up and you know the little
face shield the hinge came off and it
swung around and i was going so fast
that my face went like this and i
couldn't see and so i i it's like you
have to not panic yeah and you slow down
but like and then
like go slow enough to turn your face in
but it's so crazy because
there's so many [ __ ] things that can
go wrong on a motorcycle but it's so fun
laden splitting it it's a it's a blast
it's funny royal enfield is the one that
i really really want to get my rock
climbing buddy has one
and i've ridden on the back of it what
kind what kind does he have i don't know
the exact model but i know it's one of
the rare ones that they only made for
two years and then only is it a
different is it a cool color it's
gorgeous it's like silver with like
black and yellow yeah i think that's the
bullet it's the uh i got the i got the
the baby blue it's funny that my every
all of my other friends that ride
including my brother they all read
harley's
and being like an 80s heavy metal fan
like that's the one that i've always
wanted up until recently like everyone
on the back of an end field and i'm like
oh i think this is you know you tell him
you tell him it's the harley of india
babe
you know it's funny he told me uh my
climbing buddies like look you'll you'll
go somewhere on sunset boulevard and
there'll be a row of harleys lined up
but no one's going to comment on any of
the harleys if they see royal 100 always
comment on that everybody always says
something about mine and i walked out uh
uh i wrote it to somewhere one time and
i walked out and some guy had his dog on
there he was taking a picture of it and
like the nails were digging into the
seat and like
what do i do here you know it was kind
of like a pause it's like okay the guy's
taking a picture but then you see the
thing's nails digging into the leather
and i'm like
dog was it chihuahua yeah let me push
back a little bit okay mr animal right
if the if the dog is small enough to be
sitting on a motorcycle seat presumably
it's not heavy enough for its nails to
do damage to the seat you tell me
because the thing was just like and then
like he picked it up and i was like hey
what's going on that was just shake
that's just how they all okay and then
when he pulled it out the leather came
with his fingernails so it's like if i
was like a
you know
well i think it's less about the dog and
it's more about the person i've learned
that some people in the world and you
can sometimes tell when you meet someone
just right right they've never been
slapped
some people just have never
gotten their ass beat before and you can
tell
wow i had a dream that i got beat up in
my dream like
last night last night how i got the
[ __ ] crap beat out of me they were
like trying to like punch back but it
feels like you're punching and you're
like underwater yeah yeah
i had a dream the other night and i
don't really dream that much that some
guy was just like putting things in my
hand
in prison to
keister and it was a
and it was a pager and it was a broken
and half pager like the the the clip was
off and i'm like in your dream i got to
put this up my and then like i woke up
and then i imagine it's a premonition
it's like a oh [ __ ] dude don't even
start with that
that's
kind of pretty i have weird weird dreams
like like there's some dismemberment and
then jar jar binks pops up out of
nowhere and all of a sudden like
tweety's there but tweety turns into big
bird from obsessed it's like weird stuff
happens in my dreams how often do you
dream every night do you dream every
night steve uh i would say so yeah and
you know what i think that um
i've been um taking melatonin like a lot
you know i like it i take melatonin
every night and i'm finding that
melatonin really like makes dreams more
vivid
yeah i dreamed twice every six months
like i don't
remember did you write them down i'm
crazy no yes you write them down no i
write them down they're
wow they're weird sometimes sometimes
i'll like pull them out huh do you think
they mean something um you know there
have been a few times especially in the
last like year and a half and this could
just be me
looking to make it a reality but there
have been times where i have like
deciphered it or like what's it what's
it called when you
interpret interpret yeah so i've done
the interpreting thing and
it ends up being like extremely accurate
in like a spooky way and sometimes i'll
like double check with my friends just
be like am i crazy so i'll like if i
have a dream that feels like it might
mean something i'll tell someone
and then in like a week or two if that
thing ends up coming true i'll hit up
that friend and be like yo guess what
happened and then i'll have like a kind
of like a
person to go off of
just so i know i'm not like insane
um but much like
witchcraft or tarot cards or dream
interpretation all the things like i
don't know how real it is like it could
be
me literally just manifesting it law of
attraction style and me like it just
being the power of the mind it could be
that it's real or it could be that i'm
just making it all up and it's not
actually real but i do know that there
are results and i've seen results so it
doesn't really
matter to me whether it's real or not if
i'm seeing results and it feels good
then i'm like oh yeah i feel like dreams
are like you're living out you in
another multiverse you know it's like
some kind of [ __ ] going down well what's
interesting is
i my dreams are so real that like i can
feel the facial hair on someone i can
smell their cologne i can like it feels
just as real as this
but i feel like the only reason why i
consider this to be reality is because
this one lasts longer
like this one is the most consistent one
yeah like some of my dreams are just as
real as this they just they're shorter
and yeah
i i would agree with all of that just
except for the fact that there's just so
much like negative [ __ ] that goes on
in my dreams a lot of the time like
and uh and there's also like just so
much abstract like just [ __ ] that
doesn't make any sense that like just a
floating baby right for me to give
weight for me to lend credibility to the
things that happened in my dream and and
like ascribe to that some kind of
meaning
like
i just would be lending credibility to
some negative [ __ ] a lot of the time
that i don't even want to entertain
yeah
there's a lot of negative stuff in this
reality too though that you're right
about to turn it back to ishmael but
that's like
youtube comments
comments
comments
right yeah for sure there's no there's
no doubt about yeah there's probably
just as much negative in both worlds
that
when did you read ishmael
recently recently
and you know there's a second one i have
it actually i finished the book that i
was reading today and i planned on after
i leave here starting the story of p
story
it's the second one i was going to start
it tonight after i left here you know i
started the story of b and and didn't uh
get it didn't ever really get the
momentum going with it the destroyer b
starts with uh the phenomenon of locks
is that right
i don't know
but i remember in ishmael he kept saying
bwana
and and i kept listening he's like yes
buana and he said it throughout the
whole audiobook that i it drove me so
nuts that i pulled over to a barnes and
noble and
found the book and read and he kept
calling the guy buana it's like
b-w-a-n-a yeah which is like a sign of
respect in african cultures
okay this is such a fascinating book
yeah i gotta give you my book i got i've
got um
two now the my first one
came out in 2011
and uh new york times best seller five
star rating on amazon it's like my my uh
proudest [ __ ] that i ever made and now
my second book comes out next month on
september 27th can people pre-order that
steve they can pre-order it and if you
pre-order it
um that's the the way to get an
autographed copy of the hard cover when
it's new it's that guy my little trick
to try to sell pre-orders where can they
pre-order it at sema.com right at the
top of the website you can uh
you can he's gonna
thank you so yeah but i would love to
share that with you that would be super
cool do you have any tours coming up
yeah i'm going on tour with a revival
list which is super exciting um and
where can people buy tickets for this on
the revivalist's website i think they're
on my website too cool and your website
is
let me look it up i don't know
i'm telling you man i'm not like a
technology person i'm not really that's
great
good with all this stuff let's see
what's my website you could there's a
nope this is a pre-save link i don't
know maybe just on my instagram or
that that works cool all right so maybe
link in bio yeah link in bio something
yeah link in bio on the instagram very
cool yeah and uh is there anything else
that um that we can draw attention or uh
traffic to
um we're like
adagio we need everybody who's consuming
this on youtube to get into the the
video description and consume these two
music videos yeah i i did a music video
recently for my latest single lighthouse
but i also have another single coming
out relatively soon-ish and and when
when you do consume these music videos
that you find in the video description
then we want them to also subscribe to
the channel sure on which those videos
live
they can do that and ring the bell so
you can be the first to know about
future video uploads yeah leave a couple
hateful comments yeah in fact you'll pin
them on your twitter i i like when you
ask the the guest the same question that
mike tyson asks right that's a special
one yeah mike tyson at the end of the
podcast he said he said
these cameras there are millions of
people like uh while you have their
attention what do you want them to know
it's heavy man it's heavy that's heavy
um yeah i was i was pretty impressed by
it i forget what i even said it takes
you back because you're like yeah you
know what i
i i'll
i'll answer for you
yeah because i want to run this by you
it's something that i feel really
strongly about and and i love and it's
kind of uh my mantra in life which is
that
to be successful
you know is something that most
everybody wants and when we think about
what makes people successful
intelligence is helpful
right
talent is useful
but intelligence and talent are absolute
chicken [ __ ] compared to enthusiasm
enthusiasm is the engine which drives
like everything that matters you know
everything that makes one successful
motivation and willingness yeah
enthusiasm and if you break down
enthusiasm to its uh greek or latin
roots what you have is en theos which
means with god
so when you're [ __ ] on fire when
you're passionate when you're
enthusiastic
like you're doing god's work i have a
fun fact for you okay so
the word inspiration
in greek
is translated to god's breath
wow
um but breath in hebrew is the same word
as soul
so if you translate it to hebrew it
could be god's breath or god's soul
that's what i have tattooed here next to
my ishmael one day i love it
i asked you if uh if tommy lee knew that
knew about your motley crew he said oh
yeah oh yeah he knows he knows like guys
are you buddies with tommy lee yeah i
met him uh we've hung out a few times
i've known him for a few years now um i
i know brandon a little bit about his
kid who's like around my age i know
right better but yeah they're they're
all very sweet yeah
tommy's just the [ __ ] greatest man we
had so much fun with tommy on the
podcast we had so much fun with him
he's funny yeah he's fun he's funny and
he's cool and he's easy going he's like
he's like he's like there's always been
a little kid he's got that little kid
energy and and uh i feel like the dirt
mgk the dirt that that's who he like
portrayed and like that's pretty spot on
with how he was
yeah i love those books the heroin
diaries the dirt tattoos and tequila i
read this all when i was like 14 i love
them nice great great books yeah the the
i thought about the audience thing i
love the the motivation is important the
knowledge is important
like all the talent is important
um
but yeah that motivation helps with like
the leg work and like actually yeah kind
of like faith without works is dead that
whole thing it's like knowledge is power
but if you don't do anything with it
you're really not doing anything right
it has to be put into
action
yeah i think that's too what uh what
what made my dad so happy with me
calling motley crue it's like you know i
had that i was doing god's work man
calling him on [ __ ] molly crew
yeah that's cool yeah it's been super
rad too like like wonder what what a
great experience to to do this with you
thank you thank you for having me
pleasure to meet you too
yeah very good energy thank you yeah
thank you i work hard on that yeah you
can tell i mean the wendy
a little bit
i'm forever [ __ ] jealous of how much
my dog loves [ __ ] him yeah
steve became number three to win this
podcast right
well right on um yes sir
should we hit record now and start doing
it
call it there but uh but yeah if you
have any thoughts where you're like oh
dude [ __ ] like take that out just let us
know like i said man we're not i think
it's fine i don't think i said anything
too incriminating
and there you have it folks a
fascinating young lady named paris
jackson and i like to consider her a
friend
i think
i think that she'd be okay with me
saying that also uh i like to consider
rue a friend
he's a
a mischievous little guy and
i don't know if he's uh
supposed to be with us on the bus or at
my house but i think we're gonna help
find him a home and i think that i'm
gonna
just get into the habit of
finding
more homes for more animals because
that's what i'm about man
like curly from the three stooges
go ahead and google
curly c-u-r-l-y
from the three stooges and dogs
get a load of that guy saved and rescued
homed
5 000 dogs estimated in his life
that's what he was about man and i'm
taking a cue from old curly
with that
i love you and thank you
the ethiopian